daily wire has another report James
O'Keefe released new video Wednesday
from a sting operation which he talked
to a White House official who offered
insight into private White House
deliberations about Myriad issues and
concerning President Joe Biden and the
2024 election including the mental
decline of the president and widespread
dissatisfaction with vice president CA
Harris the Guerilla journalist said he
met with Charlie craigger a cyber
security policy analyst and Foreign
Affairs desk officer in the executive
office at the White House earlier this
month while
undercover and um they were at arrest
restaurant they were having
drinks
um and I guess we we'll play a little so
it's a 13-minute video that he posted of
this conversation with this guy and it
looks like it's a it's a date you know
at least the guy thought that's what it
was and let's play just like the first
couple minutes and get some of the
highlights here I work the so you're
you're pretty high up in the government
yeah I'm fairly high up I'm good at
keeping secrets and so I manage two
federal agencies the state department
and USA ID so when you say SEC it's like
security like you're protecting the
networks of the federal agency you give
all your information T the mission is to
protect information we Ser we we are
like the president's voice when we go
into meetings in terms of discussing and
and promoting the president's priorities
is he is he going to be the the Nom
yes and she will be the vice president
nominee yeah I don't there was a debate
about removing her from the ticket but
sadly they did she can't keep black stab
they quit on her in mess but with him
know I know he's got dementia yeah well
he's definitely slowing down but they
know that he has those issues I think so
shows it they're not will to say it same
thing with Harris is she's not popular
but you can't remove the first black
lady to be vice president from the
goddamn presidential ticket like what
kind of message you going to send to
like africanamerican voter how would you
spin that people would be like what the
like she's a woman and she's
multi-racial I think I think that
they're really concerned about us but
they won't say it I guess if they say it
publicly is they can't say it public no
they've got they got they say it
privately they each other but they won't
say it publicly say is uh they can't say
it public no they've got they got to
they say it privately like when they
play each other
I mean I'm just I'm just telling you
what I've heard like y you're just
telling me the truth does it make sense
no but that's that's what I've heard
I've had a meeting with Michelle Obama
at one point when I was an intern
and someone asked her will you ever run
for office and she said no emphatically
really I've seen all the my husband has
had to go through and that does not
interest me good to keeping secrets he
says that's the one that's that's his
best qualities I can keep a secret um
and then he's blabbing all the secrets
to this guy he doesn't know and has
never met before uh that's how good he
is a keep
secrets
um first of all when I heard that James
O'Keefe himself went undercover and got
this footage I assumed that he must have
had some kind of killer disguise I was
thinking mustache maybe a fat suit I was
thinking it'd be like Eddie Murphy a
Nutty Professor I thought that's what he
was going in uh fully you know full
method method acting but instead he
disguised himself as himself it's just
him like that's just how do you not
recognize that that's James o'keef he
put on glasses and that's it um hiding
in plain sight and it worked I guess
maybe the idea is that like make
yourself obviously James O'Keefe so the
other guy sees
you and then thinks well that that
obviously can't really be James O'Keefe
like it's a it's it's a reverse
psychology you're so obviously James
O'Keefe that the other guy assumes that
it's so obvious that you are James
o'keef that you must not really be James
o'keef because if you're really James
O'Keefe you would not be as obvious
about being James O'Keefe maybe that's
maybe that's the level they're playing
on here that's some real um
psychological trickery going on and but
I still don't understand how
this how does this still
work like I I know they're not going to
give away their Trade Secrets but how do
they find these guys that are just
willing to spill their guts to somebody
they don't know knowing that James
o'keef is out there and having seen this
exact video a million other times
they still fall I don't get it are you a
few years or maybe a few decades out of
school and wondering what the heck did I
even learn what was the point you might
even be thinking I don't have the time
to learn something new well if that's
you you're not alone and it's not too
late Hillsdale College is offering more
than 40 free online courses learn about
the works of CS Lewis the rise and fall
of the Roman Republic or the history of
the ancient Christian church with
Hillsdale colleges online courses if
you're not sure where to start check out
American citizenship and its decline
with Victor Davis Hansen in this eight
lecture course Victor explores the
history of citizenship in the west and
the threats it faces today threats like
the erosion of the middle class The
Disappearance of our borders the growth
of an unaccountable deep State and the
rise of globalist organizations the
course is self-paced so that you can
start whenever and wherever you want
start your free course on American
citizenship and its decline with Victor
Davis Hansen today go to hillsdale.edu
Walsh to enroll there's no cost and it's
easy to get started that's hillsdale.edu
Walsh to enroll hillsdale.edu
wolsh look if you're a Democrat
operative not that I'm trying to give
you any advice uh or help you in any way
but if you're a Democrat operative and
you're on a first date with someone who
is asking way too many questions about
your line of work then you should
probably just assume that you're being
o'keef or don't I mean it don't get me
wrong if you want to embarrass yourself
you want to continue embarrassing
yourselves I I'm you know it's great I'm
it's fantastic but for the the record um
I'm saying this this could be avoided
and actually if if you're anyone and
you're talking to anyone else who is
asking a million questions like this you
should be suspicious not that I'm
promoting paranoia I'm not saying you
should be paranoid but it's like in my
entire life okay and you could probably
think yourself it's like the same thing
in my entire life I've I've only met
maybe one person who in real life will
will listen intently and ask interesting
penetrating questions and lots of
follow-ups so that in a conversation you
feel like you're talking to Joe Rogan on
a podcast like a regular conversation
feels like a long form podcast interview
because of all the follow-up questions
and they're really interested interested
and they're asking um I met one person
in real life who is like that and uh and
that would be my wife she's the best
listener and asker of questions that
I've ever encountered in my life it's
not even close
actually maybe my whole marriage has
been a James O'Keefe's sting sting
operation I don't know but for anyone
else you should be worried because uh no
one else asks like in a normal
conversation people are just wrapped up
in their own lives and so in a normal
conversation they ask what do you do for
Liv I do this oh cool and then they move
on they don't ask anything else about it
um but as for what this person actually
said of course it should be a major
Scandal uh we've got somebody from the
White
House admitting among other things that
the president is scile and we can all
see it like we know it but he's
admitting it um and the rest of the
stuff the stuff about CA and how they
want to replace her but they can't
because she's a black woman all that is
interesting all that is newsworthy but
the Scandal is the admission by a White
House official that the president has
dementia because remember that was the
question o'keef said he has dementia and
the guy said he's slowing down for
sure and the thing is if the the
president doesn't have dementia and
somebody
says he has dementia doesn't he you
would say no he doesn't you you wouldn't
say he's slowing down for sure it's like
if somebody said he's a murderer isn't
he you wouldn't respond by saying well
he's made a lot of mistakes for sure you
would just say no he's not a murderer
explicitly it's definitely not the case
so if it needed to be confirmed we have
it confirmed from the White House from a
White House official unintentionally
confirmed you know that uh that the
president has lost his
mind and and everyone knows
it everyone at the White House knows it
the whole world knows it and we're going
to march on ahead anyway because it
doesn't matter it makes no difference
apparently uh and instead what's
happened is that the Biden campaign in
order to deal with this problem to deal
with the problem that their candidate
has lost his mind and his scile um they
are projecting and so they've ramped up
their attack
against Trump on the basis of trump
having dementia so they're now
continually tweeting out and posting all
these clips of trump supposedly uh
losing his train of thought and mumbling
and you know all the kinds of things we
see from from Biden all the time now the
the the Biden campaign is putting out
all these videos of trump supposedly
doing the same thing and the thing is
most of those clips are are pretty weak
um or they're just flat out lying about
what's in them or or they're taking a
clip of uh Trump just sort of
rambling and they're trying to frame it
like he's has dementia and they want us
to forget that well that's always been
Trump like Trump has always been when
Trump was 50 years old he's always just
kind of he's a guy that just Rambles on
the top of his head so that's always
been him that's no
different
um I so I don't know if this T tactic is
going to work on their part but this is
what it's come
to um this is this is where we are now
where we're going to have a campaign a
presidential campaign between two people
accusing each other of being scile no
you have dementia not me like that's
that's that's going to be the campaign
that's what we have that's what 2024 is
going to be um great sign great sign for
America that's that's when you know
that's when you know things are going
really
well for your country hey YouTube thanks
for listening to the show if you'd like
access to my full show with no ads you
should go to daily ir.com and use promo
code Walsh to get two months free on all
annual plans see you there